مرحبًا ، ربما يسمى موقعي بسبب
الذي لا يزال يترك نسغ البطاطا الحلوة
الخشب بني اللون
كرمز للبانتول أيضًا في يوجياكارتا
[موسيقى]
في المنتصف اسمي ياسر ذكي جدا
هو في
كعكة مرحبا ميلا من إنتاج الجد
في مصنع واحد ومنزل واحد
شيء واحد هو أنه أسس شركة
هذا ودعوة الناس حولها
هنا للعمل لأنه في ذلك الوقت
السكان هنا لا يزالون
الظروف في الحب الاستعمار الهولندي
من الصعب على مستوى إنتاجنا الغذائي
الإنتاج فقط على أساس اجتماعي
لا يمكننا الاستفادة
الحد الأقصى
[موسيقى]
MP4
المكونات f *** التي يصنع منها ميلاد
هو دقيق التابيوكا ودقيق الكسافا المائي
نحن نشكل صناديق لنا للبخار
أو نقوم بالبخار الجزء الأصعب
تفجر هذا نحن إنهاء الراتب أو في
لا يزال البخار يستخدم كحطب
لقد قمنا بالبخار هناك نمزج
حتى تصبح ناعمة
مرحبا العظة دخلت الجهاز للتو
اضغط على هذا على البخار مرة أخرى أو على البخار
مرة أخرى نحن صامتون أو مطلوبون
ليلة واحدة في الصباح نقع فيه
الماء العادي الذي نغسله لإزالته
مثل النسغ عندما نجففها
تقريبًا حتى 02.00
ظهرًا بدءًا من الساعة 06.00 صباحًا
جافة ، نقوم بتعبئتها جاهزة لـ
تسويقها
مرحبا مرحبا
مرحبًا ، أعتقد أن هذا العقد سيكون أكثر
مطاطية ولذيذة أكثر تحقق من هذا
تقدم عادة مع المعكرونة المقلية
أو نودلز مسلوقة أو قل المعكرونة المختلطة
أو هنا مختلطة لغة Magelang
أرز
قل القناع ، إنه هناك
بيض دجاج المطر أو FB sin FB ينفجر
يذكرني بالمنزل بسبب
مرحبًا ، أكل المعكرونة ، أنا أحب هذا أكثر ، وبالتحديد
في مطعم مع الأصدقاء أو
مع العائلة
مرحبا مرحبا